love this man loved working with him
loved having him here with his lovely
wife to promote their children's books
just a couple of weeks ago and now he's
here courtesy of all pro dad comm none
other than Tony Dungy how are you coach
hey rich I'm doing well and I love that
Hawaiian pizza Tony
really you're a Hawaiian pizza guy I've
had it and liked it nom sausage is still
my favorite but Hawaiian pizzas not bad
I don't know I'm from New York Tony and
when I went to the school at the
University of Michigan you know I they
were and you're you are a Michigan man
okay although University of Michigan man
that should have happened but we've
already been down that road before so
des guy there was tons of pineapple
eating people there are also people who
called sneakers tennis shoes and soda
pop and and also people actually stop
for you when you try to cross the street
in traffic in a car Tony I went home a
first break at Thanksgiving and I
thought that people in New York would do
the same I totally forgot I almost got I
almost didn't make the second semester
good chatting with you here thanks for
calling in to the show what do you think
we have learned over the first two two
weeks of this pro football season Tony
what's the one thing that you didn't
think coming in that you have learned
about this the 32 teams through two
weeks well the first thing I learned was
that I don't think we take the preseason
seriously enough and I don't think we're
gonna really know until October 1st you
have teams that just didn't work hard
enough in the preseason we don't see
exactly what they are but I think we
have learned that Jacksonville and the
Rams are very good so which team that we
haven't learned who they really are do
you think we will learn will actually be
good there are a few teams you know the
Patriots do this every year there
they're gonna pull around with their
defense experiment a little bit they'll
get better in November and December and
they're gonna be there at the end the
New Orleans Saints I have looked bad
this first couple of weeks but I think
they're going to be there at the end I
think their defense will come around as
well
those are two that right off the top of
my head I think are gonna be better than
what they've shown what about the Giants
that you saw on their television screen
in your studio right what do you think
about that I didn't see anything
encouraging at all I actually picked the
Giants to win because I thought both
teams Dallas and the Giants would try to
take away each other's running game I
thought Eli had more weapons than dak
Prescott so they would win but they
never had a chance with that offensive
line and that's hard especially in this
day and age the way practice is if you
could still practice physically and get
those guys working but now I just think
it's gonna be developing that offensive
line is gonna be tough during the year
and I think Eli is gonna take a major
feeding there and the problem for the
Giants is their schedule will not allow
them maybe even one breather of a game
where the roster that comes into their
house or they go into their house isn't
as deep as potentially theirs and we had
Trent Dilfer on the show on Monday Tony
and he said from what he could see that
Eli is operating at a faster speed with
trying to change protections pre-snap
than what the offensive line and anybody
else who is trying to communicate with
pre-snap can currently handle is that
something you can actually work on is
that something that you can actually fix
that you can fix in practice you can
save the protections and get guys on
board but even when they nuva their
blocking just one on one pass blocking
line stunts that should be very simple
to pick up or pop and scot-free those
things need work and you have to work at
full speed to get that done and I don't
think the practice plans of the NFL
teams allow that now so it's gonna be a
it's going to be hard to fix it Tony
Dungy Hall of Famer here on the Rich
Eisen show what do you make what is your
opinion on the NFL not only saying that
Tony Curran T's flag thrown on Clay
Matthews at the end of the Vikings
Packers tie was a correct call but then
sending that that video out as part of
their weekly declaration of what is
right and what will be continued to be
called and what everybody should learn
as a template moving forward what did
you think of that decision if they
actually call
that is roughing the passer consistently
there's gonna be a lot of flags and a
lot of and there'll be a lot more
passing because guys will be afraid to
hit the quarterback at all
I didn't think Matthew lifted him up he
definitely didn't drive him straight
down into the ground he hit him and took
him on a kind of a parallel course with
the ground I just thought this was
calling a little too tight you know the
rule says hey you can't forcibly put him
into the ground you can't lift him up I
thought this was called too tight
currenty did call the same penalty on on
Minnesota earlier so you know it was a
case of that's the way he's interpreting
that's where he's calling it now if I
have Toni Corinth ecole in my game this
week I'm gonna be careful how I hit the
quarterback because you're gonna get
called Tony Dungy here on the Rich Eisen
show Mike Tomlin is on your coaching
tree Tony and what do you think he is
dealing with right now in Pittsburgh
what he's dealing with losing and he's
dealing with the defense not really
playing that well and if those two
things get straightened around if the
defense plays a little better and they
make a few less mistakes and they win
these next two games all the Antonio
Brown social media all the Le'Veon Bell
talk no one will be talking about it
it's the same thing with with New
England I'm hearing all this stuff about
the book and what the coaches think
about Tom Brady and what Brady thinks
about Belichick if they lose that's
going to continue to fester all year if
they get on one of those 10 game winning
streaks
nobody's going to talk about the book
and nobody's going to talk about what's
going on so you know Steelers have had
these issues they've always had guys who
are outspoken and a little bit different
and you know and Tony O'Brien and Bill
are no different than they've been for
the last five years they've just got to
start winning and you know the Patriots
are on Sunday Night Football this week
and you and Mike Tirico and Rodney
Harrison in studio before it where the
of all people that Belichick and Brady
are trying to bounce back against it's
someone they know very well and Matt
Patricia who
could fall to on3 the latest Belichick
assistant to go elsewhere and initially
if not long-term struggle where do you
place the importance of of a coaching
tree being successful on what makes you
a great coach in terms of your legacy
what do you I think
zero I'm really proud of the guys who
worked with me you know Jim Caldwell is
going to the Super Bowl my comment going
to a Super Bowl and winning Lovie Smith
going to a Super Bowl permit worth going
to the playoffs Leslie Fraser go into
the playoffs Rod Marinelli went to
Detroit didn't win was on 16 but I'm
proud of all of those guys and but you
know it's really when you go out and
leave there's a lot of facts what
players do you have what is the
organization like what's the culture you
know every coach Bill Belichick wasn't
super successful in Cleveland okay he is
very successful in New England so it's
just it's different we can't say Bill
Belichick not a good coach his time in
Cleveland if that's all we had to judge
we might say he was just average but he
got a chance to be in a high quality
organization the perfect storm hits and
you go 20 years and when so there's a
lot of factors besides whether you're a
good coach or not or whether you know
your ex doesn't oh yeah I mean once you
once they leave the nest I mean what
control do you have over it other than I
guess what you've downloaded them
knowledge wise right coach
yeah and trying to help them through
tough situations and how do you hey if
you're my comment how do you get to sip
write it how do you get people focusing
on the assignments on the field and
forget about all this off field
distractions it's those are more of the
job description then whether you're X
the nose or a good communicator it's how
you kind of handle these storms and then
I think Mike don't do great
so Tony Dungy Hall of Famer here on the
Rich Eisen show tell me about donesies
diary at all pro dad com what's this
about yeah we've got a few neat things
they're all pro dad started in Tampa it
really started with some of our
assistant coaches with the Buccaneers
trying to figure out how we could be
better
and how we could utilize our time better
and we ended up branching out and
turning that into a program for other
men and we thought it was just going to
be local here but it's actually gone to
48 states and you know we have breakfast
in schools all over the country we're
actually sponsoring a program next
Wednesday bring your kids to school day
dad in the state of Florida just things
like that to get men connected to doing
the job of being a father a little bit
better it's a great website a lot of
tips a lot of helpful things so if guys
are saying hey I'd really like to be a
better dad I'd like to connect with my
kids better go to the website all-pro
dead calm you'll get some great
resources and great tips and and and and
learn how to eat pepperoni or pineapple
with your children this is how to make
different kinds of pieces that your kids
will enjoy yeah great chatting with you
as always
Tony really enjoyed catching up with you
hopefully we'll do it again real soon I
always enjoy always doing you better
right back at you at Tony Dungy on
Twitter great follow so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience